hi I'm Erik Bosse and spider-man far
from home has been releasing a ton of
footage in the International promo spots
hinting at interesting new developments
with Peter Parker's relationship with
late mr. stark and what he will be doing
in this summer movie and for whatever
reason the studio is saving all the good
stuff for the Chinese trailers maybe
because they think those Chinese
internet censors will block the spoilers
or that we Westerners who obsess over
breaking down every little missable
detail from trailer footage don't know
Chinese well really think ow that
translates to sort of spoiler warning
although my accent and pronunciation are
terrible because it's really hard to
understand the google translator also
this episode was sponsored by Dollar
Shave Club more details on that later
okay let's get started first a number of
promos are showing footage of Peter
Parker on the jet with happy hogan a
door in the back spirals open leading to
a lab in the back where peter uses
Starks hollow projections to design a
new suit and this is really exciting
because a big part of the Peter Parker
character is that he's a crafty engineer
who makes his own suits this Tom Holland
MCU incarnation has shown some of that
like he told Tony he built his own web
shooters which is pretty impressive and
spider-man homecoming he and Ned Jill
broke the suit that start gave them
which is also really impressive yet
still in homecoming Civil War infinity
war an end game most of the fun aspects
of Spider Man suit are really functions
at Tony Stark designed for him like he's
all Spider Man and his personality but
his suit is really more of an Iron Man
suit but now designing and building his
own suit restores Peter back to the DIY
craftsmen that the character has always
been these projections show the iron
spider suit with the extended Waldo arms
and it appears more red and gold than
the suit was an infinity war that could
be a nod of the comics when the iron
spider armor that Tony gave Peter was
intentionally given a red and gold color
palette in order to brand spider-man on
Iron Man's side of the Civil War
conflict other projections show a
simplified version of the Spider Man
suit which might be what Peter is aiming
for in his new design stripping down the
heavy functions of the iron spider armor
for a more lightweight version a 3d
printer stitches together the suit which
Peter is seen wearing another shots of
the trailers it includes a more red and
black palette and old-school Steve Ditko
Webb gliders Peter kicks off from
Happy's jet Blighty
down to that mess on the surface this
looks like the elemental monsters that
we seen the other trailers one attacking
Tower Bridge in London which could be
molten man or some views - combination
of multi man hydro man and sandman then
this new Chinese trailer spot reveals
footage of Peter receding Tony Stark's
sunglasses hello Peter hello would you
like to see what I can do these
sunglasses look like the exact ones that
Tony wore in infinity war ended endgame
the sunglasses show Peter a heads up
display including profiles of everyone
on this bus and what they're currently
doing on their phones a closer
examination shows some really
interesting Easter eggs one fellow
student texts hey mom Venice was crazy
can you transfer me more money that
means that this bus is traveling from
Venice to the next stop on the school
strip perhaps Prague or the airport's
London and also cjv smoothes character
mr. Dell one of the chaperones on the
school trip his photo is hilarious and
he's looking up the history of
witchcraft maybe he's shaken up I see in
the magic of Mysterio sorcery on the
canals of Venice then there's Martin
stars
teacher character mr. Harrington he's
writing looks like things are looking up
finally some good luck and to the right
of them that looks like MJ reading a
book so you know no digital privacy
there for Peter - indeed there's also
Ned and Betty Brant now booze texting
each other miss you and Missy more but
before we get to them there's actually
the most interesting detail hidden in
this footage but before I get to that
thank you to Dollar Shave Club for
sponsoring this episode
whenever I'm cosplaying as my favorite
Marvel characters I got to remember to
groom up this woodland creature because
a Peter Parker should not have neck
hairs poking out of his suit and whether
I'm shaving or showering or brushing my
teeth Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to help you look feel and smell
your best
yeah Dollar Shave Club offers a lot more
than just shaving products that covers
all your grooming needs in one box they
actually sent me all of their starter
sets let's check it out the shave
starter set comes with the executive
razor in 3 1 ounce tubes of their dr.
Carver's shave products there's prep
scrub shea butter and post shave do the
oral care starter set comes with a
weighty toothbrush in a trial size
toothpaste and the shower starter set
comes with the trial sized body cleanser
the shampoo and the citrus and Hawaiian
ginger face cleanser which I love
because I have super pale gingery skin
and now it smells like oranges basically
if you have a body Dollar Shave Club has
you covered sorry disembodied voices
like Friday or Dervis and right now
they're offering each of these sets for
only 5 bucks you ship them right to your
front door and the more you buy the more
you save they call it the handsome
discount and at least I feel handsome
join the club with one of their starters
that's for just 5 dollars and after that
the restock box shifts regular sized
products at a regular price get this
exclusive deal at dollarshaveclub.com
slash new rockstars to day ok back to
the trailer footage another profile
shows Nouman a car the actors playing
the character who seems to be named
Dimitri in this movie now he could be
the driver of this bus or someone else
joining their trip we also saw a car's
character in the other footage operating
one of the computer terminals in the
secret command center with Nick Fury
Maria Hill and Quentin Beck so maybe
Dimitri could be one of Beck's or Furies
operatives secretly embedded with Peter
Parker on his field trip posing as bus
driver or tour guide to spy on Peter or
give Peter backup or Intel in each new
location as they try to pull Peter away
from enjoying himself into these
missions learning exactly who Dimitri is
and that he's with them could be why
Peter seemed to be so mind blown in the
shot from the other trailer moving on
there are other promos that have been
released featuring Quentin Beck giving
Peter a speech into HomePath
people depend on you even if you were in
a battle sometimes they die this line
makes me suspect that Beck's coziness
with collateral damage might raise a red
flag for Peter that Becca's less of a
hero than he claims to be also he's
Mysterio who's you know one of the most
famous spider-man villains there are
also more shots of Peter in his cool
black stealth suit and Prague which
seems to be maybe a suit that Nick Fury
gave him to cover his tracks so that you
know people won't put together
spider-man and Peter Parker keep showing
up in the same European cities sister
Sarah connection there yeah yeah they're
the same also Tom Holland just keeps
introducing stuff a spider-man Taccone
meets finally there was one more leaked
longer trailer with longer versions of
shots we've already seen but it also
introduces Peter swinging MJ through New
York and MJ showing up with Peter in a
stealth suit his hotel room as Ned walks
in and there's an interesting comics
Easter egg from Aunt May in this footage
she asks Peter if you took down the
Manfredi mob now in the spider-man
comics Silvio Manfredi is the villain
Silvermane and in the other trailer
footage we've seen of spider-man taking
out those gangsters in a restaurant
maybe these gangsters are part of the
Manfredi mob behind the chandelier there
is a person wearing a leopard print suit
and heels which I once speculated could
be a version of Kraven the hunter but
maybe that's this movies take on
Silvermane and this would be a smaller
spider-man villain that Peter has to
thwart in New York before heading off
into the main international plot of far
from home comment down below with what
would you most be embarrassed for a
Peter Parker was Tony Stark sunglasses
to read you looking at on your phone
yeah let me know that and follow me on
instagram and twitter at a boss and
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns of everything spider-man and
Marvel related thank you for joining me
and my most embarrassing iPhone moment
probably when I searched how to cosplay
as spider-man without everyone knowing
whether you've been circumcised
yeah my apologies to anyone who paid to
see that
[Music]